here's quint hughes  hughes attack and goes behind the  pass at the back of the goal as he tried  to send it to elias patterson and that  comes mikhail graham the nice lead pass  duchesne is in he scores  matt duchene with a deep to the backhand  and a shot to the roof and the predators  have pulled even at two  and creates a chance tries to feed elias  patterson now brock fester is the other  defenseman besser is the guy filling in  for quinn youth  and he can't quite get back on matt  duchene who and  what a move  fake shot and you can see thatcher demko  goes for that shot  drops his shoulder and thatcher damko  just collapsed a little bit and duchene  backhand up and in